تدفق الاسلحه الغربيه الى اوكرانيا لا
يزال مستمرا اذا بل ان الامر بلغ درجه
التنويع في العتاد بارسال اسلحه اكثر
تطورا اخر الاسلحه التي ستصل الى اوكرانيا
انظمه رادار للدفاع الجوي المزود سيكون
فرنسا التي قررت اذا ارسال انظمه رادار
لتتبع تهديدات الصواريخ والمسيرات الروسيه
هذا ما كشف عنه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي وصف ارسال هذه الرادارات بمثابه
الكرز على الكعكه على حد تعبيره كما اكد
وزير الدفاع الفرنسي سيباستيانو ارسال
فرنسا للرادارات الحربيه وذلك بهدف انقاذ
ارواح الاوكرانيين على حد وصفه انظمه
الرادارات الفرنسيه التي سيتم ارسالها
لاوكرانيا الهدف منها حسب وزاره الدفاع
الفرنسيه حمايه المناطق الاهله بالسكان
وتسمى هذه الرادارات نظام جراوند ماستر
200 وهي رادارات متوسطه المدى تصنعها شركه
الفرنسيه
جي ام 200 هو رادار عباره عن جهاز استشعار
للدفاع الجوي قادر على تغطيه دائره قطرها
250 كيلومتر ويمكن تشغيل هذا الرادار عن
بعد كما انه يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي قادر
ايضا على استشعار الاصوات اللاسلكيه
تستطيع هذه الرادارات تتبع طائرات
هليكوبتر وصواريخ الكروز وايضا قذائف
الهاون والمسيرات حتى ان كانت من وراء
التضاريس